so Ivan in the late 60s had made the
first uh what we would call today a
virtual reality headset um he used
different terminology but but similar he
said that he was building a bridge to a
virtual world which is a term that
actually came from art criticism believe
it or not from Suzanne Langer an art
theorist from earlier uh in the in the
20th century and so I read this and I
was so excited because I thought wow if
you can just make an arbitrary world
that's this thing that's this thing I've
wanted and there wasn't an internet then
so I used to just run to strangers on
the street and show them this journal
article and there's just like this
really awkward 15-year-old kid and it's
just like stop you have to look at this
we're all going to share our dreams
through this computer thing like okay
okay like you know yeah and um so uh I I
uh I uh just a little while later it's
actually only a few years later in my
early 20s actually started the first
what I called virtual reality company
and I thought virtual reality would be
the term that made it social like
consensus reality and if it was social
then people would see each other they
could turn into fantastic birds and
other creatures and then they would have
this shared experience that might be a
new frontier of connection so that's
that's what it was for me but of course
we have to pretend it actually was this
industrial operation which it also was
but that was always the core for me tell
me those early dates you say I I started
in this but of course it wasn't like
Silicon Valley looks like it does now
what was Silicon Valley like in those
early years and when you say you started
H how I mean this is as you say an era
when we were still grappling with the
notion of the first internet and just
simply being able to look at information
that leap into virtual reality was still
a long way off yeah well when I showed
up in Silicon Valley which was right at
the started the 80s um it was already
there it was already called Silicon
Valley um apple and Microsoft were both
two or three years old um they were
known um there was already a sense of
excitement a sense of the future and I
fell in with what we call the hacker
crowd the the the uh the kids who were
good with computers who were creating
this new society and I have to say the
feeling was very different back then
there was a kind of a sweetness to it
that I think is lacking now and in fact
there was a disdain for money uh people
who were seeking money were held in
contempt I mean I remember one of my
first
conversations uh I had run into Steve
Jobs and some people who work for him
and then I was talking to a bunch of
hackers they saying ah jobs you know he
tried to work at Atari on this Chip he
didn't get anywhere so he decided to do
this stupid money stuff instead and to
them it was this incredible Fall From
Grace being a successful entrepreneur
was like this lesser thing that somebody
who couldn't hack would do just to be
close to the real stuff the real hacking
you know and so it's a very different it
was it was a different culture it was
very hippie-ish which I guess I still
retain um it was uh um it was uh very
experimental it was very optimistic it
was very silly it was very young yeah uh
I mean I remember uh the the the way I
ended up starting a company was not with
any vision of oh I'm going to be an
entrepreneur it was more um oh God it'll
I'm afraid you'll get the wrong
impression if I tell you these stories
because you have to get you know get a
balanced impression from reading the
whole book but one there was one all
night 24-hour uh sort of horrible greasy
spoon eery where we'd all gather and it
had electrical outlets and so you know
how today you go and you work in a in a
in a place with your laptop well in
those days the computers were huge they
were um like if you look at some of
these speakers on this array here the
computer monitors were as big as two of
those together and we'd actually haul
these giant things in and then take over
a whole table just to set up one
computer and and then work through the
night and so there was this uh the guy
who ran this place would be behind his
counter with this spear trying to spear
the rats and he would he would shriek
like an and um we started rooting for
the rates and they got names they were
never caught and so what happened is uh
we were talking about all this
virtuality stuff and I was ready
building I I had uh made a successful
video gam so I had royalties from a
video game so all the money went into
building virtual reality prototypes but
without any business or anything it was
just this garage project and so one day
one of my friends said you know if any
of us put half the effort that this guy
puts into spearing The Rats we could
like build these companies like why are
we just sitting here and so it was
actually this rat spearing thing that
inspired us yeah to yeah
yeah of course I think these days the
spearing of the rats is trapping you all
in behavior modification Loops through
social media so in a sense the the
metaphor persists but we're going to get
there what when did you when did you get
a a sense Dar that that was changing
that actually it was the moneymen or the
money makers or the people who could
work out the business model for the work
you were doing when did that mood that
that that that notion of Silicon Valley
start changing you know I
think sometime around Google sometime
around when Google started up because we
up until that time
we never had this feeling of it was
always kind of a generous thing we're
going to give you these great tools
we're going to give you these things
that you can use um and then Google see
this is so Google was saying no actually
we're going to keep your data and uh
we're going to organize Society we know
how to improve and optimize the world
now I should say I'm not speaking ill of
Google on a personal level my friends
and I sold them a company uh part of me
is there they're my friends I actually
really like Google but there was a very
strange thing that happened around the
time that Google started which is uh
there was this
uh very thick very intense absolutely
inviable feeling in the hacker community
that things should be free free music
free email and if anyone suggested well
if there was even the most minuscal
postage of would discourage spam if
there was even you know maybe we should
give people a way to make a living since
someday they might lose out to
automations and all that why don't we do
that any notion of that kind was just
viciously shut down people really wanted
this free thing but the problem is that
that project to make this kind of free
service would still be embedded in this
commercial world where people had to pay
their rent and people were making
companies and it was it was a m it was a
capitalist context so by default the
business plans that are left if you make
everything free are pretty um indirect
and strange and so you can say
advertising but then here's the thing um
if you're Google started out placing ads
but if you're constantly measuring
somebody and then changing the feedback
they get you've you cross this threshold
where you're no longer doing advertising
and now you're in the world of
behaviorist manipulation you're doing
direct behavior modification
incrementally and and to call that
advertising completely misses the point
but the problem is that companies like
Google were giv no choice that was the
option available to them so I think what
happen because of the funding they were
offered and the returns they needed to
make and the fact that did you not joh
did you not need to to build businesses
that were profitable if you're going to
build a business it has to be profitable
I mean that's the deal you know that why
else would you do it I mean uh why would
so so the thing is we were saying yes
build profitable businesses but no don't
sell anything it all has to be free so
what you get then is is behavior
manipulation I mean we we meaning the
idealistic kind of Lefty
hippie uh class of people uh gave them
little choice so I I mean I want I want
that to be clear this was not like some
evil scheme where they came like ah
we're going to take over the world and
manipulate everybody we you know it was
actually more a very well-intentioned
kind of sweet ideology that just
backfired terribly that's my view of it
and you were very critical then as we
moved on onto the whole notion which is
connected to to this AR you've just made
about Web 2.0 and the notion of sharing
data and this idea that this was somehow
connecting the world and was a super
good thing and social media you've
talked about digital maoism um what what
was it you meant by that and you've
touched a couple of times already um on
this idea that um they are modifying our
behavior and that they they are sort of
manipulating what people think they want
so I started writing cautionary essays
around '92 I was the the the timeline is
I built this the first virtual reality
company in the ' 80s and then I left it
in 1992 and that's where this this
Memoir cuts off and then shortly after
that I started writing cautionary essays
um and if I may say so
um I wish they were bad essays I wish I
was wrong I wish I had not been preent
because unfortunately some of these
things which seemed rather dark and
paranoid have come true almost you know
very closely uh to what I what I wrote
and I I I hate that I want to be wrong
when I'm dark you know but uh the the
the what the the notion that concerned
me was uh um well first of all uh if you
have little programs that are giving
feedback to people and manipulating them
um those programs will as a matter of
course uh cluster people into groups
that that oppose each other and this is
just a natural optimization this is like
this is just a thing that will happen
it's it's not it doesn't have to be
planned um and so then you start
organizing people into the these
opposing groups and then they become
annoyed with each other they become more
and more addicted more and more uh
involved but then there's this other
thing so I have I had a hypothesis um
called the uh pack switch and so the
notion is that people are similar to say
uh coyotes or some other animals that
can either function as loners or as
members of packs and when that switch is
turned inside of inside us and we feel
we're a member of a pack our whole sense
of perception our ethics our morality
our personality changes and it becomes
all about the pack and and what we must
do is avoid setting that switch uh we
must remain individuals in order to be
decent to each other when we turn into a
mob and this is what I meant by digital
maoism um what was interesting to me
about some experiments on the left as
well as on the right is there were
occasions when people started Ed with
good intentions but they ended up with
this horrible violence and these
atrocities and I I suspect what's
happening is they underappreciated this
this switch that's inside all of us so
the question I asked is if we start
manipulating with these digital Loops
why won't we create social catastrophes
of people turning on each other turning
tribal uh why won't this destabilize
Society completely and uh this is what I
fear is happening now and this is some
of the outcome maybe we're seeing now do
you think ultimately what you were
writing in the '90s yeah it certainly
appears to me to be a description of
what's going on in the US now yeah what
was it in the is it the business model
is the advertising model is the
algorithms they use are they like
betting companies so they they have
these heart stopping moments so they are
addictive you talked about the adct
you've talked about the addiction what
is it that they are using a funny thing
happened last week there was an
interview of me published in the New
York Times about this addiction thing
and the next day one of the Facebook
book founder Sean Parker came out and
said yeah actually we intentionally did
that which was an Open Secret everybody
has known that but now it's on the
record um so if you wish to addict a
creature uh you uh give them feedback in
exchange for the actions you wish them
to perform but slightly inconsistent
feedback so that it's not too mechanical
so they have to keep on grasping it how
to get there to make the feedback more
and more consistent so if you have a rat
in a behaviorist experiment and the rat
is supposed to hit a button to get a
treat sometimes it works sometimes it
doesn't sometimes it's a little delayed
and you have to vary it a little bit to
get the rat super obsessed with how to
really get this thing going and people
find it hard to resist that and so if
you set up a feedback loop with that
quality you addict people and this is
something casinos know all about this is
something conmen know all about um and
uh we we uh formalized it into code or
well you know Facebook did and and some
of the other social social media
companies um and it it's a uh it's a
legacy of behaviorist research in uh
manipulating behavior and and and uh
this is something that can be done but
should not be done we can't have a
decent Society we can't have people with
their own valtion we can't have a
society that progresses we can't have uh
a society based on empathy or kindness
if people are constantly being
manipulated from some Central source no
matter what type of source that is um do
you think it was a cynical Act was it a
cynical act to build a business because
you said Google are your friends they
bought one of your businesses they are
you know they are people that have
brought also brought of course great
wealth and to not just to themselves but
to you know people no I mean it's the
most spectacular and quick wealth
creation in history and I mean if you
look at the list of the world's
wealthiest individuals now most of them
especially the new ones are close to
some digital hub of some kind you know
that that's where the wealth is now um I
can't speak to whether it was cynical
because I was not there I I um it's I
suspect it was
more sort of like kids goofing around
and being sort of bad boys are not
taking it too seriously and then it just
kind of took off and and they saw stuff
that worked yeah I mean I think what
happens is if you have a spectacular
level of success especially when you're
young you take it as some kind of
message from the universe and maybe you
lose your standards a little bit I I'm
not sure though I that and that I I
wasn't there so that one I don't really
know about I can't speak to it and what
about some solutions to that and what we
could now do as users of these sides
what is it that needs to to happen to
break this relationship well I
mean I think there's a few things that
everyone is obligated to do and it's
work honestly it's not like uh it's not
super easy
um okay I should make clear I'm speaking
only for myself uh I you mentioned that
I have a a connection with Microsoft
when I'm out doing my books I have a
very strict boundary and I say things
that are definitely not Microsoft
approved uh Microsoft owns a social
network called LinkedIn and yet I'm
about to tell you delete all your social
media accounts just stop don't do it
it's stupid stop stop doing it you think
that you're just having fun watching
your favorite whatever football team or
keeping up with with uh relatives um
you're being watched you're being
manipulated just stop doing it get off
it figure out some other way to do those
things you're smart you don't have to do
it but is there a way is there a way
though is it right where I've never been
on one I don't see I seem to be able to
sell books I mean I don't I think this
this whole notion that if you don't do
it you'll be left out in the cold and
you'll die it's it's wrong I think you
all you have to do is simply stop and
life is fine do you think that
with but surely these social media
companies or let's Facebook or whether
or or other technology companies have
also brought great advantages to the
world surely and and maybe from the west
and maybe our slightly comfortable
audience here maybe we can delete it but
if you're a you're a campaigner in Syria
and Facebook can actually link you to
the world that's a very good thing well
see what happens is there's a pattern to
how this works and and this is actually
in a way we're getting into what I'm
writing about in a follow-on book that
isn't announced this isn't really in the
present book but um the pattern is that
initially people who are trying to do
good works and there are spectacular
good works that occur over social media
and um I could talk about the me too
movement right now which I think is
doing a lot of good but uh that one
hasn't played out yet so let me talk
about black lives matter from an earlier
time okay so with black lives matter you
have had a social media campaign that
really did raise awareness about a
horrible phenomenon in the US where
unarmed young black men typically or
other other people of color would be end
up dead after what seemed like a routine
traffic stop and it just kept on
happening and happening in various
variations and so initially there was
this extraordinary success of the social
media aspect of black black lives matter
people got together they organized but
the thing is while they were doing this
that and there's and I'm not in any
sense questioning the validity of it and
in fact I'll even go further and I'll
say um in the US black Twitter as a
social phenomenon itself as a sort of
form of literature spectacular and
beautiful and an amazing thing all of
that is true the problem is that
simultaneously with that the algorithms
are classifying all these people who are
participating in it as well as other
people who are reacting and then
gradually it turns those two groups
against each other because if it can use
them to annoy each other it increases
engagement which is its prime directive
so then a little later on suddenly black
lives matter is turned into this thing
that's used to annoy and engage this
other group meanwhile other groups are
used to annoy and engage black lives
matter that all just happens as a matter
of course by the functioning of the
algorithms whose job is to maximize
engagement but then when people come
along who are
sabur who um and there were this whole
business of sort of Bad actors is a
really interesting thing they're all
kinds of Bad actors the ones we're
talking about now quite a bit are um
Russian intelligence services that wish
to intervene um in the US but there are
also sometimes just nasty people um
weirdo rich people who want to prove
they can change the world sometimes they
organized crime interests that get
involved in one way or
another the the metaphor I like for
understanding the role of all of these
Bad actors is they're the gut bacteria
of of social media they're this other
force that co-evolved with social media
that provides a lot of energy and motion
and momentum that wouldn't be there
otherwise and so there's a codependence
anyway when these Bad actors come in
they see that the algorithms are
starting to divide people to increase
engagement and then all they have to do
is latch on that and they can make it
worse and worse so suddenly black lives
matter became a fulcrum for for harming
the society for tearing it apart for
making people crazy and paranoid for
making no one trust anything no one know
what's no one could tell it's true
anymore everything became more and more
crazy so despite the the TR the validity
and the beauty of the initial wave which
is always there it's Then followed up by
something that's completely degrading
and disruptive and ridiculous and
disconnected from reality so the
question is will this happen to the me
to movement now and the answer is yeah
probably because that's how this
works
that